-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-All right, here we are on CNN,
your home turf.
He directed, wrote, produced,
and starred in the new movie,
Somewhere in Queens.
-Ray Romano is over here.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
BILL MAHER:
It's on Hulu. I loved it.
She is the anchor
of CNN's Laura Coates Live.
You all know Laura Coates.
-Okay!
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
BILL: Your big star
and novelist, and host
of the America This Week
podcast, Walter Kirn,
-who's as funny as ever tonight.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Okay, so these--
I hold in my hand,
-these are--
the people write in...
-(RAY ROMANO LAUGHS)
...and here are their questions.
We don't know what they are.
"What does the panel think
of Oprah revealing
she used a weight loss drug?
How dramatically will drugs
like Ozempic
impact the obesity epidemic
in America?"
Well, it's already happened.
-It's already, you know--
-Mm-hmm.
And I think Oprah
was very complimentary
about Ozempic, right?
Already, was--
I knew she'd used a drug
because she kept the weight off.
-(BILL CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
It seems like
every other Oprah diet
hasn't worked,
so it had to be something,
right?
-BILL: Right.
-I think Oprah looks wonderful,
-but I will say, I'm glad...
-(LAUGHS)
...that she's talking
about the lack of it.
There should not be shame
associated with what
people are doing.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-However, you know...
if it's gonna turn into,
"You get an Ozempic,
and you get one,
and you get one,"
-different story.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(LAUGHS)
-Can I ask a question?
Please do.
Are we okay with Ozempic?
Is there a--
What's the downside?
-Well...
-WALTER KIRN: We don't know yet.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Yeah.
I'm hearing good-- (LAUGHS)
I hear good things.
Right.
In that it's not only gonna be
useful for weight loss,
but-- but addiction.
I mean, it does something
to your brain.
I-- I don't know.
I mean, would I use it? No.
-I don't-- That's--
-And you use everything, right?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(GUESTS LAUGH)
And I am a drug aficionado.
-Yes, you're right.
-Yes, yes. Uh-huh.
But... (CHUCKLES)
-Ray, this is for you.
-Oh.
"Do you think a show like
Everybody Loves Raymond
that appealed to people
all over the political spectrum
would be successful today
in our polarized country?"
I mean, it'd more successful.
I mean,
it's what this country needs.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
But here I am answering for you.
It's hard to say.
I mean,
the landscape has changed,
TV has changed.
And live-- a live sitcom
in front of an audience
-is kind of a throwback thing.
-BILL: Yeah, yeah.
But I think, at the end,
you know, funny is funny
if it's done right.
I think-- I think it can survive
if you do it right.
I'm much more worried
about stand-up.
-I mean--
-Stand-up, yeah.
You know, I mean, somebody,
a friend we both know,
was telling me about
performing recently
at some place,
and there was, like,
mostly millennials,
and she goes into her act
and she's hysterically funny,
and she said there was this,
like, feeling of like,
"Oh, the old person
is doing jokes."
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
'Cause that's, like, corny now.
Jokes are corny, Ray.
-Don't tell jokes. It's corny.
-Well, I still go to the clubs.
When I'm in New York,
I go to the Cellar, and--
And please, keep telling jokes.
They're funny.
-Yeah, yes. (LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Don't let the millennials
dissuade you.
The next time
you gotta tell 'em in acronyms.
You gotta do
the whole bit in just,
"TTYL, LMFA--," whatever it is,
and you're fine.
Yes. Yeah, it'll be a day
where they don't laugh.
They just go, "LOL, LOL, LOL."
-(GUESTS LAUGH)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
That's what
you gotta worry about.
Right. Okay.
-See, you are good at this.
-No.
"How will Shohei Ohtani's
landmark 700 million-dollar deal
with the Dodgers change baseball
and professional sports?"
I don't know if it'll change it.
-(CHUCKLES)
-It's just always moving up.
Yeah, it's always been
going up, yeah.
It's why I invested
in the Mets when I did.
And people said, "You're crazy.
Why are you buying a piece
of a baseball team?"
I said, "Because sports
is the one thing
that always goes up."
And it's the--
Because... I did a piece
on this one week,
it's the one thing
you can trust.
Yeah.
Because I know that
those people who play baseball,
those are the absolute best
600 baseball players
in the world.
There is no favoritism.
There's no nepo-babies
in sports.
You just gotta show up
and do the best.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-And you know...
if LeBron James' kid isn't good,
he won't play.
-Right.
-As great a story as that is,
he won't play.
Ohtani's changing the sport
by being a double...
an athlete
who can pitch and hit.
I mean, that's unheard of.
-So...
-Well, Babe Ruth did it.
-Yeah, and that's it, right?
-But--
-Right.
-Yeah.
So, you're saying
there was a gap.
-(LAUGHS) Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I-- This may be
an outlier opinion on this,
but I think... because I think
that the way athletes...
elite athletes work,
it's a mental thing.
You know, when nobody broke
the four-minute mile,
and then one guy did
and everybody did.
Right.
I think that'll happen
with this too.
I think
there will be other people
who hit and pitch...
-Well, that's what I'm saying.
-...because one guy--
That's why he's gonna change.
That's how it's gonna change.
-Oh, right, yes, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-LAURA COATES:
Well, I got news for you.
-(CHUCKLES)
You'll always be the outlier
when you can invest
in a sports team.
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(RAY SNICKERS)
-Absolutely.
-LAURA: Oh, come on.
-Maybe I am richer
than you are!
-Just saying! Just saying!
(GUESTS LAUGH)
-But you know how--
-You're gaining on me.
-Yeah, I know.
-LAURA: You can.
But you know what's changing?
If that is the amount
of the contract,
that explains
the 25-dollar hot dog.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-BILL: Yeah.
Is there really
a 25-dollar hot dog?
I mean, it's like,
you get a hot dog,
-you get a soda...
-BILL: Oh, I know.
...you might get a pretzel.
The Cracker Jack toy
is not even, like, a real toy.
It's paper.
I mean, it's a whole thing.
-BILL: Right, right.
-It's a whole thing now.
No, I never understand
the American economy.
-LAURA: Mm-mm.
-I don't.
Like, Taylor Swift tickets.
I read somewhere
that the average spent
-is 1,300 dollars.
-LAURA: Yeah.
-That includes, like, travel...
-(AUDIENCE GASPING)
-...and merchandise, but like--
-Mm-hmm.
Like, that many people
have that much money to waste?
I mean,
-can you imagine going to--
-WALTER:
The thing is they don't.
They don't have
that much money to waste.
They beg, borrow.
They charge up
their credit card.
-Yeah.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
BILL: I think they get it
from their parents.
Right, yeah.
They get it from their parents,
and then they turn
into Hunter Biden later,
-because, you know--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(RAY LAUGHS)
-BILL: Uh-huh.
Oh, boy, poor Hunter Biden.
"Laura, what do you think
of Jack Smith
taking Trump's immunity claim
directly to the Supreme Court?"
Brilliant. Why not go straight
to the horse's mouth?
I mean-- Or nine of them.
I mean,
you're gonna have to have a time
when you know it's ending up
in the Supreme Court.
So, why go through
all the rigamarole,
and that circuitous route?
Just give me the answer,
is he immune or not?
Do I have a case?
Is there a trial in March?
Now, Ray claims
he's not smart enough
-to do this show...
-No.
-...but he plainly is.
-(LAURA CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Just pretend he isn't,
-and explain
the background of this.
-Yeah.
-Right. (CHUCKLES) Sorry.
-Thanks for that. Dumb it down.
-Dumb it down.
-No, no, no! Not dumb it down.
But I mean,
people may not have heard
-about immunity...
-Yeah.
...and I'm a little fuzzy
on this too, so you--
So, Jack and Jill
went up a hill.
-(BILL LAUGHS)
-And then they...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(GUESTS LAUGHING)
...No!
Honestly, here's what happened.
Really, it's this.
Remember that statement
by Nixon,
"If the President does it,
it's not illegal."
-Right.
-Remember that statement.
Well, everything
a president does
is not an official
presidential act.
Going to the bathroom,
campaigning, committing a crime.
These aren't things
that are in the wheelhouse
of a president
in the same respect.
So, trying to figure out,
if it's not
what your official duty is,
do you get the protection
of being able to say,
"You can't touch me,
you can't prosecute me,
-'cause everything I'm doing
is part of the job."
-BILL: Okay, but--
That's the immunity issue.
Which of his four trials
does this pertain to?
This pertains
to the January 6th trial
-in Washington, D.C.
-BILL: So, the big one?
The big one.
-The federal trial
about election subversion.
-BILL: Right.
He's trying to claim
that everything he said
leading up to January 6th
and really on January 6th,
was all part
of a presidential duty,
and therefore,
"I can't be prosecuted."
You gotta know
the answer to that question
before you go forward
with the trial,
'cause if he's right,
and if the court sides with him,
a lot of these cases
at the federal level go, "Poof."
-Gone.
-BILL: I saw today that
Trump is beating Biden
by ten points, 48 to 38.
And only last month,
Biden was up by four.
He lost 14 points in a month,
and it's a month
where the economy
seemed to be getting better.
It seemed like inflation
is getting more under control.
The stock market
just hit a record high.
What was
the 14-point loss about?
It can't all be Hunter Biden.
-I know we love
to pile on Hunter Biden, but--
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-I don't know.
I feel like people talk about
the "feelonomics," right?
-How I feel about something...
-BILL: Right. Right.
...more than
what the actual data is.
And I'm far from my,
you know, home turf,
talking about inflation
and everything else.
I know how much milk costs.
I know how much my gas costs.
I know how I feel about both.
But people are not always
on-board and saying,
"You might be telling me
all the wins you have,
but if I don't feel
-like I'm winning...
-BILL: Right.
...then I'm not winning,
and you won't either."
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL: I also--
So, riddle me this.
I saw in the paper this week
that somebody asked Biden
if they thought
he was the only one
who could beat Trump,
which I always thought
was the whole reason
why this person who--
I like Joe, but I don't think
he should be the candidate.
But I thought
that's the whole raison d'être
for the-- He said,
"Yeah, I think about 50."
He said he thought 50 Democrats
could beat Trump.
-Then why are you there?
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
-Who do we--
-And why do-- Why is--
Name one. Who is the one
you think that can be--
Well, as James Carville said.
He said any centrist Democrat,
like, fifty-ish...
-LAURA: Hmm.
-...a lot of it's an age thing,
could do it,
and I kind of agree.
And Gavin Newsom
is gonna be on our first show.
-I've been--
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
He looks like... (CHUCKLES)
...a pretty strong candidate
to me.
All right, we gotta go.
Thank you very-- Oh, I'm sorry.
-Did you wanna...
-LAURA: No, I was just
gonna say,
everybody loves Ray,
you should run.
-Oh, no, don't...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
We like him too much for that.
Thank you, everybody.
-We'll see you next week.
-You don't want that.